[Music]
on this sunday night promises passed
over
the consensus across party lines waiting
and waiting and waiting
for some significant response from the
federal government and quite frankly has
been absent as premiers collectively
renew a plea to the pm for more health
care funding
heartbreak and horror in saskatchewan as
the body of a missing five-year-old boy
is found plus abortion provider
protection i'm scared for all of the
women and people with uteruses that
won't have access to this could canadian
doctors helping u.s patients face
criminal charges
and a big dinosaur discovery this is a
highlight of my career in many ways that
may explain why the t-rex had such small
arms
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight
nitu garcia good evening and thanks for
joining us the country's premiers open
up two days of meetings tomorrow in
victoria while each leader will arrive
with their own set of priorities they're
united on one thing forcing prime
minister justin trudeau to live up to
what they say is a promise he made to
seriously address their long-standing
demand for a boost to federal health
care funding our chief political
correspondent david aiken is following
the story for us tonight david
we'll need to during the worst of the
pandemic prime minister justin trudeau
met often with the premiers and when he
did he promised them he would deal with
their pleas for more health care funding
once the crisis had passed the premiers
now say that promise has been all but
ignored and i've been waiting and
waiting and waiting
for some significant response from the
federal government and it quite frankly
has been absent we just keep getting
brushed off
i find it amazing because this is i
think after inflation the country's top
priority
the provinces are hugely stretched the
trudeau government argues it is
increasing health transfers to the
provinces every year according to the
formula established by the harper
government federal transfers increase at
a minimum rate of 3 percent plus
inflation annually the premiers argue
that formula does not work in an era
when the population is not only getting
older but living longer we need to go
beyond inflation plus three percent or
some
sterile
fiscal arrangement we need to understand
the needs going forward the premiers
will begin their meetings as a growing
number of hospital administrators have
recently been forced to close emergency
rooms or cut back on service last month
at the maine children's hospital in
ottawa the average emergency room wait
time surpassed three and a half hours we
need a strategy
for making sure that canada has the
health professionals this year and in
all the years going forward
to be able to address the demands that
we face meanwhile the survival of
trudeau's minority government hinges on
keeping the support of jug meet singh's
ndp and that support is contingent on
the liberals setting up a national
dental care plan and a national
pharmacare plan neither can proceed
without the premiers but before we get
to that point we have to be deal with
these basic principles the issue is icu
beds and doctors and nurses critical
care acute care
and long-term care these are the
priorities of i think pretty much all of
the problems mental health now this
united front by the premiers crosses all
party lines be it a new democrat like
horgan a conservative like kenny or the
country's only liberal premier right now
newfoundland labrador is andrew fury
they are all insistent the federal
government must provide more funding for
health care
david aiken reporting tonight thanks
david
minister of natural resources jonathan
wilkinson says canada has agreed to
return a sanctioned russian natural gas
turbine at the request of german
officials ottawa says it's issuing what
it calls a time limited and revocable
permit to facilitate its return to help
ensure the continued flow of natural gas
to europe the turbine from the nord
stream one pipeline was sent to montreal
for repairs by russia's gazprom but
became stranded due to sanctions over
the invasion of ukraine germany said its
return before winter is crucial but
ukrainian officials have called the move
a dangerous precedent
russia is ramping up its assault in
ukraine's east not only on government
targets but civilian infrastructure
killing at least 15 people after russian
rockets hit a five-story apartment block
in the donetsk region
at least five people have been freed
from under the rubble but frantic rescue
efforts are ongoing to try to save
dozens more who are feared trapped
russia's defense ministry says its
forces also struck ukrainian hangars in
the donetsk region that were storing u.s
made artillery
as russia's military seizes control over
much of eastern ukraine the question is
what is russia's ultimate goal would
russia be willing to stop fighting if
the kremlin can claim victory in the
dawn bass either way would ukraine
accept a cease-fire with russia still
occupying that region one thing is
certain as eric sorensen reports the
fighting is taking a toll on both sides
they are dispiriting scenes for
ukrainians russian soldiers posing
showing off after taking lissy chansk
russia has performed better in recent
combat in eastern ukraine
the russian armed forces continue to
strike military facilities in ukraine
says the military official including
airstrikes on u.s made missile launchers
in donetsk
but the ukrainians remain defiant
we will return said president vladimir
zelinski ukraine he says does not give
anything up
while the russians appear willing to
wage a long war of attrition against a
smaller ukrainian military the
ukrainians are motivated to fight for
their homeland and are being resupplied
with more long-range military hardware
from nato there's going to be more
equipment flowing into ukraine from the
west
the russians are exhausting their
supplies to a certain degree this could
be very difficult for both sides
but i think it's going to be
particularly hard for the russians the
war has become a grinding battle for
land in eastern ukraine from crimea to
the donbass russian forces have slowly
seized control of almost all of the
luhansk region and uk defense
intelligence now expects russia's focus
to switch to capturing donetsk to
achieve moscow's stated goal of
liberating the donbass this may be
russian president vladimir putin's
endgame to secure control of the donbass
and forced ukraine to accept the
ceasefire on those terms then he can say
that he liberated these territories and
now it's on on to ukraine to accept that
reality so i think that's what his
objective is right now but whatever
gains russia is making on the ground it
is losing on other fronts the loss of
the european marketplace for russian
energy will have long-term consequences
deutschland
[Applause]
germany has depended on russian energy
for too long chancellor olaf schultz
saying the country must get off russian
energy as quickly as possible and then
there is the expansion of nato this
isn't a historic day for sweden and
finland the two nordic countries moving
a step closer to joining the alliance is
a disastrous outcome for moscow which
had aimed to divide and weaken the west
two well-developed countries that have
modern militaries and can
add much to the alliance
so
this is an absolute failure
for putin
the sad reality for civilians in ukraine
is that the war shows no signs of
winding down soon it is one more way in
which russian success on the battlefield
may yield few benefits having destroyed
much of what they have taken over and
rousing anger and destroying relations
with a next door neighbor that could
last generations
eric sorensen global news toronto
there is tragic news out of saskatchewan
tonight the body of five-year-old frank
young has been found police confirmed
the boy's body was found saturday near
the area where he was first reported
missing in april frank young was last
seen playing outside of his home in red
earth cree nation about 300 kilometers
north of saskatoon rcmp say there is no
indication of suspicious circumstances
january 6 committee members
investigating the riot at the u.s
capitol are urging people to tune in
this week for more eye-opening details
about former president donald trump as
jennifer johnson reports lawmakers hope
to deliver damning evidence showing the
former president encouraged the attack
with the goal of overturning the
election
the january 6 committee hits the home
stretch this week painting a picture for
americans of a president who tried
everything he could to change the course
of history the overall message that we
have been gathering out of all of these
witnesses is that the president knew he
had lost the election and that he was
casting about for ways in which he could
retain power that included talks of
seizing voting machines in several
states telling the vice president not to
certify the election results and
inviting white nationalists and militia
groups like the proud boys and oath
keepers to lead an assault on the
capital the attempt to overthrow the
result of a presidential election
through a political coup
and the mobilization
of an armed violent mob
it makes the watergate break-in look
like the work of cub scouts this week
the public will hear tape testimony from
former white house counsel pat cipoloni
who according to a previous witness gave
a serious warning to those in the oval
office trying to overturn the election
results
we're going to get charged with every
crime imaginable the committee is laying
out the case for possible criminal
charges against donald trump including
conspiracy to defraud the united states
and obstruction of an official
proceeding blocking congress's counting
of the electoral votes no man is above
the law so if that's where the facts
lead that's what has to happen committee
members promised bombshell testimony
this week the rest of the country knew
that there was an insurrection the
president obviously had to have known
there was an insurrection so where was
he what was he doing it's a very
important hearing pay attention still
recent polls show most republican voters
believe the january 6 riot was a
legitimate protest and not an
insurrection and those numbers continue
to grow
i got gasoline down to 1.87
[Music]
the former president remains on the
campaign trail and is still attracting
big crowds but the committee believes
history will be on its side and in a few
years trump will be shunned by his party
as richard nixon once was
jennifer johnson global news washington
u.s president joe biden says he's asked
his administration to consider whether
he has authority to declare an abortion
related public health emergency biden
made the comments to reporters during a
bike ride today he's been under pressure
from his own party to take action after
the landmark decision last month to
overturn roe v wade which upended
decades of protections for women's
reproductive rights
we can do a lot of things
to accommodate
the rights of women
in the meantime but fundamentally the
only thing that's going to change this
is if we have a national law
of union states roe v wade that's the
bottom line
as abortion laws change across many u.s
states there are concerns canadian
abortion providers could be held liable
or even charged criminally for providing
an abortion to a u.s citizen as heather
urex west reports a national body that
helps doctors navigate legal issues is
now asking the federal government for
help
mississippi's last remaining abortion
clinic has now closed a judge denied
this week an injunction to stop a
statewide abortion ban from taking
effect it's heartbreaking i'm angry i'm
sad and i'm scared i'm scared for all of
the women and people with uteruses that
won't have access to this those seeking
an abortion
will now need to travel out of state or
out of country
but here in canada there are new
questions around whether doctors can
safely provide that service to them i
think this is a really
difficult situation because it's
something that we haven't encountered
before and we don't have a lot of
experience and there's just a lot of
unknowns there are fears canadian
abortion providers could face legal
trouble for offering non-residents care
in a letter to the federal ministers of
health and families children in social
development the canadian medical
protective association said
the cmpa is aware that some american
states are contemplating legislation
that would potentially allow for
criminal charges and civil legal actions
to be brought against health care
providers who provide abortions to
residents out of the state we are
writing to ask the federal government
work with the provincial and territorial
governments to ensure liability
protection is available to canadian
physicians there's not a lot that can be
done by the federal government from a
legal perspective certainly from a
diplomatic perspective those
conversations might happen and states
may be encouraged to keep their abortion
laws within state boundaries the
potential chilling effect that these
things can have
can set up a really dangerous
environment where people are then
experiencing even more barriers to
access the canadian government has said
the country is open to americans seeking
abortions but so far when it comes to
u.s patients providers in this country
have not seen an increase in demand
something that could change however as
more u.s abortion clinics close
heather urex west global news calgary
coming up occupied and ousted the latest
on the collapse of sri lanka's
government
plus the growing death toll as a gunman
opens fire inside a bar in south africa
a day after storming government
buildings and burning down the prime
minister's residence hundreds of sri
lankans are vowing to continue their
occupation until the island nation's
president officially resigns
we don't trust him anymore because
he has already
broken our trust our country's trust he
has already sold our country so we are
not in the position to trust him or our
prime minister at the moment
the president and prime minister offered
to resign after protesters stormed both
of their homes but not until wednesday
sri lanka's opposition parties say
they're working to agree on a new
government thousands flooded colombo on
saturday demanding the resignations
following months of protests the leaders
have been blamed for sri lanka's soaring
inflation and growing shortages of food
fuel and medicine
today citizens of japan voted in the
shadows of the assassination of the
country's former prime minister shinzo
abe abe a key figure in japan's liberal
democratic party was gunned down friday
in the western city of nara during a
campaign speech in support of a local
candidate japan's ruling party led by
prime minister fumio kashida an abe
protege is projected to win the upper
house election the latest exit polls
show the conservative coalition is
poised to take between 69 and 83 of 125
seats which would increase the
government's majority in the upper house
in south africa 15 people are dead and
several more injured after gunmen opened
fire at a bar near johannesburg the
suspect stormed the busy tavern just
after midnight armed with automatic
rifles and handguns police say the
victims were shot at random while they
were drinking the gunman fled the scene
and no arrests have been made the
shooting comes two weeks after 21
teenagers were found dead in another
south african bar the cause of those
deaths is still
unknown ahead the potentially
life-saving procedure involving human
waste and why it's harder than ever to
access it
you may have heard of becoming a blood
donor or an organ donor but have you
ever heard of donating your personal
waste a fecal microbial transplant or
fmt can be life-saving but as jamie
morocco reports covit has made accessing
the procedure more difficult than ever
this is what it takes for stephanie
pezzamenti to survive this is the
dressings the 38 year old diagnosed with
a host of chronic illnesses is bound to
a central iv line because of digestive
tract paralysis
basically my whole home has become a
medical setup
i have medical supplies iv poles and
this all got
all came about after my first seed of
infection
the digestive system is home to
thousands of good bacteria but there are
cases where the bad like clostridium d's
difficile commonly known as c difficile
can take over
in 20 to 60 percent of c difficile
patients like in stephanie's case the
infection keeps coming back despite
antibiotics in about five percent of the
time
the infection can become very very
severe to the point where yes their
their bowel is so inflamed it sort of
starts to get distended
gastroenterologist dr dina cow says the
best option is a fecal microbial
transplantation or fmt
taking stool from a healthy donor and
placing it in an infected patient often
via colonoscopy to help restore good
bacteria but when the pandemic hit those
procedures were put on hold
health canada as well as the fda they
also issued a warning about how covet
could potentially be transmitted through
screening has mitigated the risk but a
lack of donors and backlogs have set
appointments way behind cow and her
colleagues have joined a growing number
of researchers working on new poop pills
freeze drying and encapsulating stool so
patients can be treated at home
in london ontario st joseph's hospital
became the first clinic in that province
to offer the capsules
stephanie says she can't even get in for
a consult until the fall
i don't want to die
and it's
it's sad that we know that this could
work and i can't access it stephanie's
condition worsened over the weekend
she's back in hospital a situation she's
all too familiar with she says she's
suffering from a perforated bowel a rare
life-threatening complication of c
difficile and one that will require
urgent surgery jamie morocco global news
toronto
next what these fossils found in
argentina reveal about how predatory
dinosaurs evolved
a team in argentina has discovered a new
dinosaur species as mike armstrong
explains the miraxis gigas was similar
to the tyrannosaurus rex but predated it
by about 20 million years
when dinosaurs roamed this land it
looked very different hot and humid
not dry and hard in fact very hard
well these images are from
paleontologists 10 years ago discovering
something from about 90 million years
ago
we are thinking that maybe this animal
died and was dried
and
partially crushed
femur no the team has been back to the
site four times over the last decade
digging through hard sandstone this week
they published their findings not only
did they discover one of the most
complete skulls of a large meat-eating
dinosaur ever but it turned out to be a
species that has never been found before
oh th this is this is a highlight of my
career in in many ways peter mcavicky is
one of the leaders of what was an
international team it actually included
a canadian paleontologist as well it was
the team that got to pick the new
dinosaur's name they went with miraxis
gigas miraxis was a dragon in a game of
thrones book and a member of the team is
a fan we bandied about several other
possible names um
this one had sort of the the best ring
to it i would say
kind of rolls off the tongue
now miraxis was about the size of a
school bus it was more than 10 meters
long and more than 4 000 kilograms but
one thing that makes the discovery
particularly important is what it says
about evolution miraxis evolved
completely separately from other
big-headed and small-armed dinosaurs the
tyrannosaurus rex for example didn't
come around for about 20 million more
years but they both somehow evolved in
the same way their arms got smaller as
their heads grew bigger and more
important for hunting they're the main
tool if you will for procuring
and manipulating food items of
presumably very large size
the team is still studying the fossils
they recovered at the site and will go
back there's much more to be excavated
and there may still be secrets to be
uncovered
mike armstrong global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm nintu garcia tonight's
your canada is my hometown penticton
british columbia thanks for watching
good night
[Music]
you